trente ans de chansons 30 ans de poésie
et de colère bien sûr entouré de blocage
c'est le village françois béranger est à
la goutte d'or pour trois semaines
accueilli par le lavoir moderne un bep
ranger fidèle à ses protestations
après tant répandent à nu
les années 70 ans pouvait encore espérer
le mans allait changer en mieux en bien
en faisait des idées désillusion on
était plein de toppi de nos rêves puis
petit à petit on s'aperçut que tout ça
c'était la peur est un peu illusoire
effectivement la société et le monde ont
plutôt tendance à se radicaliser vers le
pire le monde va dans le mur
si on n'apprend pas à partager ce qui
ravit ventre mou pasqua tant la radio on
entend par ckoi souvent au diront enfin
sable soit toujours en dehors des modes
et des amours médiatique bérenger a
connu l'ombre et la lumière
chaleureusement suivi par un public de
fidèles est accompagné par de très bons
musiciens le chanteur est d'abord un
homme libre dans son visage aux cèpes
d'après yeux elle a une broche et de
monsieur critiques à faire sur mal la
carrière déjà longue
bien que intermittente c'est de ne pas
avoir été assez subversif mais si
c'était à refaire
si j'avais 30 ans de moi je leur ferai
mais beaucoup plus saignant quoi parce
que je pense que j'étais bien trop
gentille bérenger le verbe cru et
réaliste touchant à force de ne pas
changer
m